les arbres dominique fortier j'ai dévoré
votre dernier livre les villes de papier
c'est un moment délicat sur la poétesse
emily dickinson tout au long de votre
carrière vous avez été fasciné par le
19e siècle
pourquoi avoir choisi emily dickinson
cette fois ce jeu j'aurais le goût de
vous répondre que c'est elle qui m'a
choisie mais ça comme polaire vrai mais
en même temps ça allait un peu j'ai
commencé à écrire se développe quand
j'étais aux prises avec un autre roman
sur lequel je travaillais depuis des
années qu'ils étaient une grosse affaire
très compliquée qui se passait sur
plusieurs époques avec plein de
personnages et dans lequel j'étais
extrêmement malheureuse j'arrivais à
rien mais je m'obstine à travailler
parce que des syndromes d'abonnés lève
puis j'écrivais une page plus nos pages
que j'étais jamais satisfait jusqu'à ce
que une nuit j'aimerais veille on était
à la mer en une maison qui est vraiment
proche la mer puis d'eau douce on entend
les bagues très fort l'année ce qui fait
que je me réveillais plusieurs fois par
nuit et puis je me suis réveillé avec ce
personnage là qui est d'une simplicité
absolue
une femme tout seul dans une chambre je
me suis dit mais si paul le livre très
compliqué avec les dizaines de
personnages sur 1,8 époque qu'il faut
que je raconte c'est cette ville qu'est
ce qui t'arrive est le livre compliqué a
gelé
pour inciter à manger je limite côté
j'en ai fait un fichier que j'ai
sauvegardé que j'ai envoyé à mon éditeur
que j'ai dit en gros que l'ouvrir après
ma mort mais on ferait rien avec en
attendant et non y'a jamais il jamais
réussi après votre mort entre emily
dickinson elle voulait pas qu'on publie
deux survivants la majorité de ces ses
poèmes et emilie a demandé à sa soeur de
brûler tout ce qui était de l'ordre de
ses papiers personnels donc sa
correspondance les brouillons des
lettres qu'elle même avait écrite celle
qu'elle avait reçus et puis la vigne en
faisant le tri dans ses papiers est
tombé sur ses quelque 2000 poèmes qui me
dit avait écrit au cours des dernières
années de sa vie surtout et qu'elle
avait pour l'essentiel jamais montrer à
personne je veux vraiment saluer votre
intelligence et votre flair parce que
pour le livre les villes de papier vous
aviez un éditeur au québec mais vous
avez décidé de l'envoyer par la poste
aux éditions grasset et gallimard tentez
votre chance en france et ça a été assez
payant pour vous parce que vous êtes
finaliste au prestigieux prix renaudot
le prix femina aussi alors expliqué
expliquez-moi comment vous avez tous et
cette idée l'oeil comment vous êtes
allés de l'avant et j'avais déjà depuis
quelques ouvrages un éditeur en france
qui telle une bonne maison mais avec
laquelle je me sentais pas le même lien
que je me sens depuis toujours avec alto
je ne sais mais est ce que l'on pourrait
pas essayer de faire autre chose que je
me faisais répondre mais tu sais pas si
compliqué les grandes maisons sont une
approche à la magouille tout ça je suis
ok mais dans le fond moi ya très peu de
choses que je peux faire mais il ya
cette chose extrêmement simple qui est
de prendre mon manuscrit s'étaient pas
encore un livre à ce moment là c'est
vraiment un paquet de feuilles de le
mettre dans une enveloppe puis de
l'envoyer aux deux maisons que j'aime
puis dont je sens qu'elle pourrait être
ma famille littéraire j'ai eu la très
grande chance quelle enveloppe chez
grasset se retrouvent
entre les mains de quelqu'un qui
s'appelle chloé deschamps qui est aussi
l'éditrice d'autres et oui l'ami et
qu'il a lu qu'il aimait et qui a
contacté cette personne imaginaire qui
signe le livre parce qu'en fait je
l'avais envoyé sous pseudonyme parce que
je n'avais pas le goût qui ait aucune
influence ni positive ni négative au
fait que soit une hauteur qui avait déjà
publié que je sois une québécoise
j'avais le goût que ce livre arrive
comme comme s'ils avaient été écrits par
personne et pour moi c'était vraiment
comme un message dans une bouteille que
j'envoyais j'ai été extrêmement touché
par cette oeuvre
qu'est ce qui m'étonne de vous et ce qui
ne fonctionne pas dans le casse tête
c'est que vous avez un doctorat en
littérature française université mcgill
est reconnu comme traductrice votre
plume est superbe mais vous avez attendu
l'âge de 36 ans avant de publier un
premier roman
pourquoi avoir attendu aussi longtemps
parce que la littérature ça me terrorise
et l'idée d'écrire c'est quelque chose
qui pour moi était comme impossible ce
test est inaccessible peut-être ça
explique le fait que j'ai étudié la
littérature si longtemps est pour moi un
auteur le site est quelqu'un qui était
mort depuis quand on pense qu'ils
étaient préférablement un homme faut se
le dire parce que le corpus classique
qu'on nous apprend l'école c'est
beaucoup ça et donc je non je ne me
sentais pas le courage de faire ce
pendant très longtemps
puis arrivé à l'âge de 36 ans m
je pense que je me suis si je le fais
pas maintenant je le ferai jamais
si je le fais jamais je vais le
regretter en terminant dans quelques
jours vous allez savoir si vous
remportez soit le prix femina ou le prix
renaudot
comment vous vu et tout ça j'essaie de
ne pas penser à la suite parce que c'est
un peu étourdissant c'est à quelque
chose de vertigineux puis surtout seuil
est complètement hors de mon contrôle
c'est dans les mains des lecteurs des
jurys donc je le prends avec la distance
nécessaire comme les sorties on se
croise les doigts d'une main
oui merci